he's definitely gonna take a piss or
no he's chilling he already did all
that steve i'm gonna slap both your
faces
he's too cute to smack around he really
is and he seems very fragile i'm not
going to lie to you he's you drop that
thing he's going to break some bones
that's my joke where like like um you
ever have you ever seen something that
was so cute you want to kill it kind of
want to kill it like like i don't want
to kill him no of course not but squeeze
it like it came from my friend at a
puppy bulldog
and it was and it was
his face was something i was like
and then i saw it wake up from a nap and
it was sleepy and it was yawning
how long are we gonna
i know that's your favorite oasis
sweatshirt he walked in i was like well
that sh sweatshirt doesn't fit there i
tried it too many times i actually think
it fits you oh yeah no stand up
stand up let me see
i like it i like a form-fitting
sweatshirt though i do too literally hey
wave to somebody
oh there you go yeah it's just a little
too short is it a little is that that
you get away with it sorted out didn't
you no it doesn't move on i don't know
yeah like you know i wasn't trying to
make family that's a tight
sweatshirt i know it's just a little
like and there's nothing worse than a
short sweatshirt yeah they bought me
they gave me this comedy works
sweatshirt you look great in there they
give you a bag
it fits
but it's just a great sweatshirt
but i think i'll wear it i i haven't
wearing it right now yeah it's got a
zipper
is this for showcasing it
it's just another accessory that you
don't want to do that's like me
with hats that's why i don't wear hats
yeah it's just another accessory
i gotta add this you don't mind
accessorizing you don't accessorize oh
yeah two necklaces watch watch it oh
yeah yeah oh yeah watches oh two
necklaces today sometimes i'll toss on
three yeah if i'm feeling frisky this is
how you're feeling who makes those i
like those uh
yeah but what are they uh jordan's is
there a collab oh the shoes yeah let me
talk about his jeans
oh i got something for you uh
really i'd say it's for a chin and
meatball i get a call from my friend
rich chao
who is uh
he's the matchmaker for bellator he's
like behind the scenes he works with
everybody ruka i mean he's balls deep in
mma he's like one of the godfathers of
it but he has a
thing that he uh does now called
uh
something wimp to champ or some
like that uh went to warrior wimp to
warrant okay so what they do is and
they're doing it in l.a no no no it's
good so they're in la
and uh it's a 20 i think 20 week
training camp
but like with legit coaches like the
most legit coaches you can get and the
training camps
all done like john canaveral wrote all
of it so he put this whole training camp
together so you have world-class coaches
you train for i think it's 20 weeks and
get in shape and then take an amateur
fight at the end whoa
meatball anybody into it meatball
i mean
i mean i gotta get that
damn back fixed would you say oh yeah
wait where's they had 50 year olds
they've had yeah it's like uh oh does oh
it doesn't matter the age no they've had
50 year olds do it you said john
cavanaugh right he put the program
together uh-huh but where they where
this camp is at in uh hawthorne
okay cool let me ball you into it yeah
and would you you should do that you
don't have to fight at the end but you
can if you want
to take an amateur fight at the end i'll
do it you'd be damned yeah you asked me
if i had anybody in mind that uh worked
that thick boy
i said chan you or eric griffin would be
down i'm down eric griffin wouldn't be
dead
guarantee uh
talk to eric so
yeah he would do the training he
wouldn't do the no yeah he said that's
the thing you don't have to that's the
thing you don't have to do the fight if
you don't want to you would go for it i
feel like meatball wants to do the yeah
you want to go all the way
you're talking about world-class
training yeah 20 weeks like he was
saying like there's like this 50 year
old dude did it he was like you'd be
blown away what he was able to do after
20 weeks yeah if i'm doing world-class
training i will 100 take the fight at
the end well here's the thing you got to
be at hawthorne for the next 20 weeks
it's 6 am to 7 30.
that's a reason but but rich will
sponsor it so you don't have to pay for
it
see you're off i could be here at 4 30
20 20 weeks and you do post a lot of
those uh videos of you in the gym
throwing those jabs and stuff so
this could be something
because
mm-hmm
it could be the start of you you just
have to get to hawthorne yeah let's see
that's the only thing that's like the
downtown where are you where do you live
north hollywood
you're tough so you wake up at four and
then you uh no ma'am you wake up you do
at 4 30. would you say no traffic yeah
that's the thing you there's no traffic
coming back would be well you're done at
seven
it wouldn't be bad it wouldn't be off
and you're only 23 yeah you got all the
energy you got to just commit to going
to sleep you know early and waking up
good diet stuff too i'm down
definitely on that up front too would
you say so we can get them on some stuff
yeah yeah you'll be different when you
come out of it no they they probably
test for this oh yeah right
you serious i don't think so dude they
barely tested i don't know you need
anything just just go train natural see
what happens it could be fun
you're a young guy it'll change you i'll
be into it all right let me talk to him
damn
what's going on it's gotta be good for
eric griffin it's just i think the
biggest problem is hawthorne
yeah that's a stretch he's a little
older and that's no error you got to
understand b they've had 56 year olds i
know i'm saying but eric will no he's
just trying to be waking up that early
that could be tough yeah it's a little
tough but how bad you want it you know
what i'm saying
night you know the way he does and then
it's like you're getting three hours of
sleep i know how bad you want it though
not bad right not that bad
i think you just want to get in shape
for his wedding but are you just going
to go to a gym it's a different kind of
shape they want to get in shape you're
rolling with a bunch of dudes yeah i
don't see their eric kind of rolling no
dangerous that's a young man's thing
i mean i'm sure there are 50 year olds
you could you could do a meatball if you
want i think i'm down i'll do it where
is that set up it's uh authority no by
the by the gym
right by tempest yeah by torrance is it
torrance uh
yeah it's right by that gym we used to
go to over there north hollywood the
hawthorne
from here
jesus oh it's south that's like right by
me actually yeah that's all you are
who i thought of china
how many people actually sign up how
many people are in that gym i wonder
whoever this is just like a campaign
this is what they do so i've done other
states it's a big deal yeah it's super
successful oh yeah oh just talk about
world-class training and then you can
take a fight at the end
that's a hundred lessons yeah that's a
lot anyway he doesn't have to pay for it
no but it's an hour and a half
hour and a half
six to six a.m to 7 30.
yeah
i was 23. i'm definitely interested in
it
yeah
you only told me a 50 year old was going
to do him like 50 year olds fights like
no dude like not everybody takes the
fights yeah he's like that's not for
them it's just learning and like getting
in shape yeah that's why they're doing
it you know are they fighting against
other people that are in the program
like this no they fight pro chappelle
of course they don't dude oh i
don't know
i was like hey don't do it don't do it
don't do it
i'd be at night
he'd be going this guy he's probably
doing the same thing in other
you're scared i mean come on man
boxing's that way like they'll they'll
they try if you have a good trainer like
teddy allison who's talking about that
they'll always try to pair you up with
somebody who's basically around your
experience and he would watch guys hit
mitts and the guy's like no my guy's
just not that experienced he wasn't
gonna hit him
yeah yeah that guy's way better he's
like you're not back i don't
know if i'm late on this but i saw a
recent picture of andy ruiz
some weight yeah he looks great yeah
that's good but jim you're originally
who i thought of because we could do
like you versus another producer maybe
jamie with rogan you could do
you could how big is jamie by the way
jamie's an athlete he's in texas too
thank you
uh
we're very loose on stern athlete around
here
oh wow nope
you sure 100 sure is he is he a pretty
big guy apparently he can ball
oh
he's big he's a big dude he's not big in
chin uh no not even there but he looks
he looks
athletic he looks like he's was a slime
song
uh when i was at the when i was at
rogan's probably got three years ago two
years ago yeah maybe a year and a half
uh yeah about a year and a half ago when
i took a covet test there so it was
about a year and a half yeah and he was
uh we were talking because he was saying
he likes to play some hoops yeah and i i
looked at him and i took him in took him
in he's he's
he's
got
a pretty good body for a guy who sits
there i don't know how much he works out
but he doesn't look bad he looks after
he looks like he's
he's played ball
yeah uh chin
but i was thinking well i doubt jamie's
gonna do it but he could do against the
producer for weighing in or some other
producer yeah that'd be kind of dope but
you're injured
i'm injured so i actually i wanted to
ask you about this too because i had to
go to the doctors again i got my blood
test
and then so they're going to probably
give me physical therapy or whatever but
so they found that i had a under
functioning thyroid
and they're asking me my doctor
recommended i go on thyroid medication
and i want to ask you guys first because
i guess you do it for life yeah you do
that serious condition yeah but it's
like it's like four to four point five
as normal on four point eight
hmm
i don't know how much that is i would
what i would do is talk to somebody
who's a a phd in this area i don't know
no there are there are guys i know i do
know a couple guys there okay please i
would like to actually specialize is
that who's a legit scientist yeah
thyroid you don't want to mess around
with your thoughts that's why i want to
make sure they're saying your thyroid's
not working properly it's under
functioning you said it's not like a lot
it's just like 4.8 so i had two family
members that had that and then did some
changes
and they came right back to normal so
maybe you're not getting you might be it
might be something that the way you're
living yeah maybe you can make some
changes to see if it see that see if you
can change it naturally first before you
go on medication but the the doctor
straight up was like recommended
medication yeah because i but i need
your permission but then i asked him
like can i do something naturally to
change it he goes well you can take over
the counter but it's not safe he didn't
give me like a real good doctors are not
there to tell you yeah that's not what
they do yeah that your diet and your
exercise could maybe bring things back
to normal that's not what they do and
then their job is to drug you in one way
yeah
yeah yeah there's a whole lot okay brian
but please if you can ask your people i
know a guy thanks appreciate it no that
isn't yeah thyroids no pumps yeah i was
like what the hell yeah i didn't go on
for this yeah my mama had to have her
thyroid removed because of cancer and
they uh she's on i mean you're
on medication yeah for real for life
your thyroid regulates everything yeah
that's your computer and your mood and
everything yeah
but i don't think that but that you
don't think that's tied to your injuries
do they no he just found in the blood
work he wanted to get blood work done oh
got it yeah did you get your
testosterone checked i did it like a few
years ago and it's like normal you
haven't done it recently no i want to do
all that stuff i would do that yeah yeah
okay i'm just curious
we'll see dude no fight camp for you not
for a little bit
you might get fixed up
yeah gotta get fixed up first where's
the guy right back
it's here no it's here right here it's
right there yeah yeah chain if i cared
about fighting i'd fight for you but god
we're so delicate appreciate that
yeah like this area here
you don't want to get punched or
attacked here that guru that's not where
you want to get stabbed
where do you want to get stabbed
uh i don't know
that's the worst not in the stomach not
an arm you don't get hit like the arm i
guess on the outside well then kimbo
tell you that forearm you want your head
you want to get grazed maybe and then
even then you're like ah or just not
being a street fight
you don't want to can't help it
man sometimes just pops off
i read it i read that
3.5 times more people get killed by
knives than by rifles in this country
may be wrong no i saw that i saw that
too yeah where did you guys see that
point
yeah it seems like a lot yeah that many
more
then rifles i don't know about guns
let's see that's yeah knife crime i know
knife knife
crime in in england is a serious problem
because they're but then i was made
that's right they carried knives i'd
rather have knives i think gun issues i
don't know oh no you get stabbed
can you name a time anybody multiple
people are killed by anything i've died
sniping people die more people killed
with knives other
other weapons than other weapons than
knife more people killed with knives
other weapons than rifles other weapons
like rifles are different and also
knives in other words yeah like bats or
whatever
well knives are pretty that's that's
across america
1500 deaths by knives are cutting
instruments
443 people killed by hammers or clubs
wow 670 killed by fist or feet
and then 300 killed by rifles sheesh
well
yeah
so are they counting the prison shanks
too
nah no no they don't know a lot of gun
statistics that they don't tell you
about like all the gun violence or gun
deaths they they're including suicides
so
yeah so
so when they cite gun statistics you got
to look at who's citing the gun
statistics they're gun control advocates
they're going to include suicide by gun
and that's always been a thing yeah yeah
so oh that's why i touched you the other
night i started what have you seen the
crown on netflix
it's won every award and finally
started watching it oh it's good it is
oh it's so i'll tell you what blew my
mind but
before you change subject um so
yeah but when uh i text you about the
the government in uh
england like the uk
so basically they have the prime
minister who's basically that would be
like equivalent to our president yeah
and then you have a queen or king yeah
but they don't give their opinion on
they don't like the prime minister but
they still have they have a lot of queen
is a figurehead
the queen but they have a council that
tells her like if she wants to make
changes but it never reflects on her no
only the prime minister yeah so so so
there's there's parliament which is and
the debates between the tories and the
labour party the labor party would be
our democrats towards the pa the
equivalent of our republicans
it's conservative and there's there's
essentially liberal
and they they battle it out and then
there's a there's a national election
and each each party um essentially puts
forth their candidates who they want
them yeah so if the tortoise they want
to be prime minister yes if the when
then then they have like so margaret
thatcher back in the day was a
representation of the tory party she was
a conservative and so if you ever watch
her it's just like anything else she
doesn't have that much power if they
have the majority votes then they they
you know they they win the day but at
the end of the day um you would see
there's a like margaret thatcher would
be trying to make a speech and even
though she is the prime minister they
are interrupting her yelling at
us like you know if i were to go to jail
as well you should i mean all that so
it's a lot of that's theater
but so the england has always been like
the united states
there's a decentralization of power
nobody has ultimate power like even the
king of queen don't have that no it
doesn't have to be but i mean
but it's fascinating it's so good it's
so now now buckingham palace the
house of windsor which is the queen's
you know they own a load of land
yeah oh they have a lot of months
scotland right they don't know they
don't know everyone have you ever looked
up and when i uh toured in london i went
to the
where they keep the the jewels yeah do
you know do you know how much they're
worth
uh they they haven't even had anybody
evaluate them because they're priceless
but they had a guy like take a stab at
it it's like four billion something
dollars you get the out of here in
that crazy insane four now there's a
there's a show on netflix i started
watching yesterday that couldn't stop
watching it's a korean show
oh
i mean good is like it's so good i can't
take it it's so crazy koreans
are they are doing some special let me
see
oh oh it's not like a game show that's
she got a one 100
tomatoes it says good acting
the acting is as good as anywhere i've
ever seen in my life
there's an article that came out
recently saying that it's on track to be
the biggest show on netflix's platform
watch this every single country
just let's watch watch i'm not sure we
can play this but we'll watch it here
it's like battle royale and the hunger
games that's what it reminded me of when
i saw the trailer
it's
good let's take a little break from
chatting with the boys because hey man
it's well documented i am a coffee
connoisseur i love me some coffee i can
remember the last time i went a single
day without a cup of coffee man i can't
remember and maybe you're sitting at
home like man my coffee's not very good
man or maybe i i
i'm not drinking as much anymore because
the coffee's not good that i have at
home well my friends that trade coffee
can change all that trade's goal is to
make every cup of coffee your best cup
ever all right the journey to to perfect
your cup of coffee starts with their
coffee quiz use a french press automatic
drip your cold brew person no problem
your answers will allow trade to pair
you with the perfect coffee to fit your
taste buds trade will match you
to coffees you love from over 400 kraft
coffees we'll send you a fresh roasted
bag as often as you would like all right
trade guarantees you'll love the first
match on the off chance you don't
they'll replace it with another bag for
free man give feedback as you sip all
right you can feel good about each cup
since trade partners with 55 small u.s
based roasters who are committed to
ethical and sustainable sourcing and
they sent me a dark roast and i took the
little quiz they sent me this dark roast
with hints of chocolate and caramel i
can't get enough of it i wake up every
freaking morning
and i just chug trade man for you guys
the viewers and listeners right now
trade is offering the first bag free and
five dollars off your bundle at checkout
to get yours go to drinktrade.com
fighter use the promo code fighter to
take the quiz to start your journey to
the perfect cup of coffee i'm telling
you guys you know i love coffee i
wouldn't promote this if it wasn't great
coffee i drank it this morning trust
your thick friend here i know coffee
trade coffee you guys are gonna love it
that's drinktrade.com fighter promo code
fighter for your first bag free and five
dollars off your bundle enjoy
drinktrade.com one reason to repair and
maintain your cars to save money that
you can then use for other important
things like your mortgage or food or fun
whatever it is man why would you choose
to spend 30 50 100 for the exact same
auto parts at a chain store or new car
dealership my friends at rockauto.com
will save you money on all this stuff
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
over 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers all right the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle all right
choose brands all right and prices that
you love best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliable low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts go to
rockauto.com right now and see all the
parts available for your car or truck
all right all the parts your car will
ever need rockauto.com
it's such a good show you
finished the whole the whole series i
know i just didn't stop though i had to
get some sleep is it one season it's one
season so far i think they're working on
a second season right now the acting and
the writing it and it's kind of what's
in a way you can see it going on in
north korea you can see that it's
something like this is probably yeah
that's what's scary yeah
this is yeah in north dakota
i give this wild idea yeah yeah they've
probably seen some like i got you
one i got one for you they were like you
know we're in north korea we need to
keep everybody together because you know
so they took a very thin piece of wire
very thin piece of wire and they would
just loop it around your collarbone just
stick it to your collarbone and then
stick it through your collarbone
just to have everybody on the same
chain just to make sure you don't but i
don't get it
like is this oh this on the show no no
sir this is actually but where would
they do it like at a restaurant
they do this in a north korean prison
camp oh yeah yeah stuff like that prison
camps anything else little things little
things jesus a little bit and when you
yeah that's the first thing i saw
like wow this probably is really
going down right now yeah in china
we don't hear about they do stuff when
you up do you ever see before
midnight when um
uh it's an amazing movie it's
trump ends in it and everything else and
it's about cuba and during the
revolution and the people that were
dissidents well they would and this
happens in north korea places they'll
put you in a little little coffin-like
cell you can't really move they put you
in this you know you just can't move you
you basically like this and they'll just
keep you there for
a good long while with just a starvation
ration jesus christ you're you're going
to fall in the line you're going to fall
on the line no matter what you do that's
interesting but this this is
this is this what's fascinating about
this is psychologically
no psychologically what it does just
like pandemic i just don't want to do it
i hear you
psychologically though you go oh i
understand why like
it's not
it's not all coerced it's voluntary
that's what's crazy about this
it's
voluntary and with enough money people
are willing to do whatever they it's
that gambling thing yeah it's that thing
where you're like i mean i can win this
you can win the game
but
yeah if it's too intense i don't like to
be stressed out at home you know i get
you yeah i really do it's like the crown
it's old school you kind of you kind of
have an idea where it's going to go you
know the history yeah yellowstone
nah nah listen that's probably really
going on right now yes that's probably
called that's what i call it
it's on channel seven it's called double
dig yeah
i totally understand yeah i i would say
don't too real yeah maybe take a
peek-a-boo but make sure if you do take
a peekaboo that you understand you're
going to get sucked in yeah you're going
to get sucked in well that's like game
of thrones only fun forever but at least
i know like dragons and yeah white
one that's like that's too real yeah i
don't like it could really happen oh you
know i tried watching was that new the
chris rock the saul movie that he did
yeah 10 minutes into i'm like well this
is awful
it was so cheesy man oh it is oh it's
tough
yeah i don't like watching serial killer
movies i think i've always seen them i
like that you don't like that stuff
yeah that was good the first thought was
really cool i saw some bees for a while
they got how many of them like seven
like yeah seven of them well because the
first one i guess was a psychological
thriller right yeah first and second are
just solid scary movies yeah
yeah oh stevie we got uh tickets for uh
horror nights horror nights it's
official don't back in october i'm there
no backing out are you going to bring
your little well i can't leave them
anywhere that thing looks like a fairy
it looks like a face yeah
it's not a dog it's a ferret with a with
a documents a dachshund's uh face yeah
it's a baby ferret how did you say it
the first time
i like that yeah that's how you chin are
you on the road again this weekend no
we're not sure what the next one's going
to be
i was eating some stuff right now sorry
i love it but uh brown said that you you
mentioned like you gave him a game plan
which sounds really cool like do other
cities and then have like land in la
last or something like that that sounds
like a good idea yeah yeah
it could be good it should be good get a
solid build for the la for sure la show
and you guys oh did you see i'm sure
it's in a current event so i just want
to bring it you don't have to bring it
up do you see the police report
on jon jones i did not i'm out
i'm out
officially out i know she ran out of you
know the hotel room with her children
covered in blood bloodies bloody lips
sweatshirts bloody and they go did you
did they did you know she's protecting
her man they go uh did he hit you and
she goes not really
like okay
and then you know you know why the cops
got called his daughter said because the
the wife was scared to go back to the
room she said can you give me another
key like i don't want to go back to room
i'm scared and the daughter goes can you
please call the cop oh no
how old is his daughter
i don't know 13 12 now this is the
youngest one i think right
read that shit's like i'm out dude
officially out he had been a police car
well the uh originally he was uh yeah
that he was resisting arrest and they
said to the cops i'd love to see you
guys uh see how you guys would do
against me all of you at once i'm like
well sir you're gonna keep doing what's
gonna tease you yeah so then i guess he
was going in and out like crying and
getting mad trying getting max you know
obviously he's clearly and then
when they handcuffed him he headbutted
the car so hard it put a dent in it and
chipped paint which is a felony because
you can't do that to a police car so
that's a felony i did not know that and
that oh yeah you can't damage a police
car so that's a felony in las vegas
and then i don't know you know because i
don't because he got arrested for
domestic violence yeah but the i don't
think the wives can press charges
but then but there's there's blood like
they've seen you know they have all that
yeah can they it's a misdemeanor charge
if she doesn't press charges
the irony is it goes away
um i don't know if that's true
well because because if the
the kids go call the cops and she has
blood on she has a she has a busted lip
and there's blood on her she goes well
he just pulled my hair
because let's say
let's say i beat up cat in here right
now and then cat goes i'm not pressing
charges yeah but the cops came and katz
has bruise and yes it doesn't work
like that sometimes they don't actually
see it uh so they would have to have
evidence the problem is that if she's
that's why they took his dna you know
that yes yes but the thing is if she
refuses to testify
you you would have a very hard time
following that through
so
now if we had witnesses and we said i
don't care what she said the only
witnesses be the kids right right and
typically that's another sketch sticky
subject so my guess is he he he moves on
and it's it's another
it's another we can figure out the the
felony on the cop car too i was i was
listening to daniel cormier talk about
this and cormier was saying
the guy has always been in trouble like
it's once it's his mo yes we all know we
can have a moment and go crazy and you
get in a fight okay when you've been in
trouble
this often i think eight times nine
times yeah now the temptation to say
something like well it's cte or
something no that's not i don't know and
i know you top out i know you and i have
talked about this that's a complete
cop-out you and i a long long time ago
privately you know a lot about john and
you know a lot about that world and
you know
the people that know him
are not surprised well she says once a
victim calls the police or someone else
calls the police to report domestic
violence the matter is out of the
victim's hand yeah
yeah
well so so even though she's going to
try to like
get arrested you get arrested the
question is does it does it is there a
case a good lawyer says there's no case
here guys yeah and a da's not going to
pick that up or a prosecutor's not going
to pick that up so he is the law
enforcement officers believe a crime was
committed they will arrest alleged
offender regardless of whether the
victim wants to press charges and that's
from that's from experience because what
happens typically is the woman says no
it's okay and then the guy kills her
yeah as soon as the cop leaves so it
says only the prosecutor can decide
whether to drop the charges that's right
and the prosecutor well in there to your
point judge may dismiss the charge
there's insufficient evidence
yeah
that's so much though there's so much
even there's witnesses at the
hotel that they're up security but it
happened in the room
so they just was there i won this
account of what the
they were saying to him yeah he said she
was shaking saying yeah the kid wanted
to call the police so there's not a
thing where like i mean because
obviously she's probably she's in
something that's like messing with her
mentally and can't like fully make that
decision like
an officer or a judge can't go like
she's not in her right mind to like
really decide if this is a hell that's
why they are a relationship so that's
why they take them out of the house you
know but that's why they arrest you so
if you if you call on a if you call
about somebody who's hitting you yeah
they will arrest that person so that
they give you like sort of that cooling
off period so nobody dies in the house
but sometimes like you you see these
situations and like
people don't realize they're in like
that hectic of a no she knows yeah yeah
but she knows she's been in some
for i think they've been together 13
years yeah by the way i don't think
she's the first time
well no we know it's not
that yeah we do know it's not yeah i
mean you guys have been in non-stop
oh i believe you i mean i mean yeah this
you know cormier said something
interesting too he said the guys the
guy's done what he wants when and how
and he's still a champion and he still
wins no the cormain made that you're
missing the but the key point there's
daniel cormier goes
if john would have if i would have beat
john i don't think he'd do this because
he would have to face himself in the
mayor because he's acting like an
he's getting arrested but do you
have season there's no repercussions
from the ufc there's no repercussions
really from the law think about it
nothing's happening he's still a
millionaire and they're still he's still
able i disagree he's still able to
compete and daniel cormay's like if me
or chael or anybody would have beat him
he'd be like i got to stop doing this i
could get serious
but he you know he still wins yeah yeah
well so do you think now that he will be
kind of he won't fight in ufc again
uh i
i bet you dana's gonna wait to see what
they're gonna do as far as legally yeah
and then i if it's you know
bad or
he's out they're not gonna ride with him
anymore and he's being difficult you
know what i'm saying yeah does the ufc
need them i was gonna that's what i was
gonna say no what's funny about all this
all of us and the entertainment they did
back in the day
is that
when jon jones goes away we'll all be
fine and we'll keep watching the ufc
we'll keep watching fighting it'll be a
whole maybe for a while
but it's not he hasn't fought in so long
and and still we're still watching we're
still talking about brian ortega we're
still talking about the other guys we
still want to see what francis ingano
and ghana is no anybody could go away in
the uc keeps on keeping on and that's
the one thing same with the nfl you know
yeah this is what uh sam who mma posted
that john posted after this
on his instagram i have way too much
trauma to consume alcohol my brain said
we can't handle anymore i believe
alcohol might pass forever turn this
nightmare into the best thing you ever
have in my life what the devil means for
bad god means for good get right back on
my horse now is the time to work hard
than ever how would you quit hitting
your wife dude how about that
how would you apologize to your wife and
kids
yeah i'm out man i'm out i used to ride
for the guy i'm out officially out
yeah the kids yeah the security are
called the cops probably
probably drunk probably coked out of his
mind
and and you know no excuse you know it
doesn't matter i know a lot of guys who
drink coke and don't touch women or
scare their kids
and then he said i just grabbed her by
the hair
let me do that yeah
i just grabbed her
there what oh you're 270 270-pound man
the pound-for-pound graves fighter on
the planet you pulled your wife by the
hair
then how'd she get a fat lip
it's insane what's that thing in ozark
the the that great opening scene
in ozarks uh that show with jason
bateman
and uh he's like in my my maid you know
she stole from my family and she begged
and she said please and my father said
you have to go and i was like father
please give her another chance he goes
this isn't the first this first time she
got caught first time
yeah if you if you've done that we know
we know
yeah i'm just wondering how much the ufc
is going to put up with it and then
you're talking about espn especially the
culture we live in now
it's going to get dicey form for the
first time i think i think you're right
yeah i think you're right i don't know
and then also it's like oh my bad i'll
quit drinking alcohol it's like
but what about all the other dude
yeah it can't be just alcohol all the
time what about all the other
and then if you're the ufc like think
about it now you're going to put
together a fight let's say you fight
someone francis and sarah gone
now you're going to do all this
promotion and bet on this guy to get his
together
you know
and how about dana this would hurt me so
bad if i was john he goes
he goes i'm not even surprised to expect
it at this point because we thought by
flying in for the big snipe of his life
on getting in the hall of fame and we
could fly him out like we should but he
was usually if he's in vegas we get him
in and out because we know it's you know
he's like a gremlin after midnight we
can't have him here
he didn't say that i did
but he goes uh with the hall of fame he
goes he came with his wife and kids so
he thought he was good
yeah he's like i figured kids are good
but i guess they got in a fight because
he came back to the room after and was
getting ten thousand dollars cash
because he wanted to go to the strip
club well she was like well can you
could you not so i have a theory on that
you set him with his wife and kids what
jon jones is gonna do is he's going to
manufacture a fight jon jones is going
to get himself into a fight with his
wife so he has an excuse to go you can't
keep him there i think you're giving too
much credit i don't think he's asking
her what to do that's that poor woman i
mean he just goes yeah but then but then
to to deal with the guilt whatever that
is he's probably like you start a fight
just so you have a reason to get out
because otherwise no you're talking
about you have to see you're talking
about like regular al bundy nine to five
problems he's going i'm going to
i'm going to club and he's probably
hammering she's like whoa you're drunk
he's like yeah i'm just getting my cash
remember the strip club and then it's
you know true
underlying issues there and it's a
nightmare you think nightmare yeah man
you said they've been getting 13 years
oh wow man it's like you had one job
one job no i mean who are his handlers
how how does he not have people around
can't handle him just being like dude
what are you doing
i mean you can't have numb nuts around
them you know
you couldn't handle them nobody could
handle them what are you going to do i
don't want to handle it have to try to
give him some advice and i don't want to
handle that guy yeah he's too early
that's his problem yeah yeah especially
at his age right right right right right
right right right right right right
right right is still doing this
34 34 oh he's my age gun to your head
this is a tough question is is
is he a sociopath
um
i i hate asking that question i really
do give me the definition of so we throw
that term around a lot let me see the
definition so somebody i think clearly a
narcissist there's that a person let me
see it a person whose personality
disorder manifests itself in extreme
antisocial
ah no no
yeah i'll use sociopath is he just he's
just a complicated guy
you've trained with him you know
i don't know him that well i mean not to
you know i don't i wish i was you know
clinically uh
capable of diagnosing what he's you know
how they say people are bad he like they
go bad guy no i don't think he's bad
she's a complicated guy with demons i
don't think he's a bad guy i think he is
one of the guys that fame and success
went to his head and turned him into
what he is now so he was i knew him
before all this happened remember he was
the co-main event when i was the main
event against roy nelson okay and he was
there this was not that this was a
different john yeah he was such a
positive guy now he could have been just
faking the funk and could have been a
piece of before then i don't know
but usually yeah fame and money but
let's but like so my thing with him is
this
he what are the what is the app i don't
have a lot of friends well what is the
trouble he actually got into it's all
drug and co drug and alcohol related
every time do you know what i'm saying
am i wrong about that so in other words
he hit
his just drunk and high hit a woman
in a car ran away
um what were the other things he's done
he got a wreck in his bentley's hometown
right had like girls again this was
every time it's been when he's on yeah
so in a way it might be that he's got
you know substance of problems yeah yeah
and then that year ago though so we know
what happened today or not today but
recently but this is a year ago okay uh
so ufc john jones have arrested you back
on several charges all right uh may 2012
jones was involved in accident we drove
the current telephone pole in new york
in new york
jones was arrested driving under the
influence there you go pleaded guilty he
was not since any jail time said paid a
fine so there you go again no
consequences uh 2014 lead up to 178 uh
jones and dale career involved in
altercation during fight week uh two
need to be separated all right that
doesn't count please don't put that on
this list john was scheduled to fight
ufc 1821 prior he fight test potted for
you know stuff okay don't put that on
the list john's fresh shows his win
riding high when he again found himself
in legal trouble jones was arrested in
albuquerque new mexico after leaving the
scene of a hit-and-run jones was charged
with a felony leaving the scene of a
crime they had a marijuana pipe all
right one of the victims he'd run
pregnant woman jones stream the police
18 months of probation and community
service again
no consequences but so they don't look
at this history and go like like he was
but he there's no there's no he wasn't
drunk in that when he hit that lady it
doesn't seem i think he was i heard he
was
right because he ran away so remember
when he hit her he ran away and then
came back and he came back to get cash
and cash
out 2019 jones was charged with battery
font claims a waitress that jones hit
her and salted her plead no contest
charged place on 90 day probation again
no consequences so now hold on the last
three years jones has had a fair share
of trouble with drug testing you'll see
failed i don't care about any of that uh
you know so a lot so it sounds to me
well i remember he got on there during
the pandemic he got uh
arrested for a dui because he he was
shooting a gun
i remember shooting a gun talking almost
in the morning yeah yeah it sounds to me
like he he has a an alcohol yes and you
guys know people right yes when they
drink they're just completely different
i know people like that yeah yeah yeah
they're terrible so it's it seems to me
that if john isn't an alcoholic drug
addict he's an addict
yeah he's a way better person
yeah right
now now here's my other again i don't
like i don't
i think he likes to party he always has
and you know and i'm sure addiction has
an issue to do with it but
you know to say it's alcohol drugs and
ct i think is a cop-out right i just
think it's just people
super happy and making bad decisions
like spending all their money but
they're not
hitting they're not hitting their wives
they're not you know doing it from the
children yeah i mean what are we talking
about so in a way sometimes when you get
drunk it brings out
who you really are who you really are
yes right
i don't know man i don't know no it does
but but but even his like that post the
arrogance like ah it's all good man but
it's like it's not dude we're sick of
this yeah how about that how about
we don't give a if you fight again
how about that dude you were thinking
about that yeah we don't care man yeah
that's that's a good point
we do there's no consequences for him it
shows you he posts that that weird thing
being like i'm just not gonna drink
alkaline man my brain doesn't do well on
it god is good devil is evil yeah see it
the next it's like what the dude
yeah do you not realize the magnitude of
what you did dude
hitting your wife right your children
are scared and they call the cops on you
it's insane
even for a cage fire dana's like yeah we
gotta see what happens there you know
it's nuts excuse me i don't know how
long women put up with it you know
kids everything a bad name i didn't give
the ufc a bad name because especially
where they're at now he hasn't really
compete outright and they're not they
don't really market him you know like
i'm telling you he don't give a
remember when he was like negotiating
130 million damn's like cool dude we
can't pay that yeah he's like if he
fights again great if not we don't
really it's you know
i wonder if his brothers are probably
calling him on his ass right now
i mean again i don't know if he's
controllable yeah yeah i don't know who
he is if you have somebody who has
demons i i we all have experience i know
you do i know i do
alcohol can really change somebody's
life change somebody to the point where
they are beyond reason you are not
moving them you're not getting out
you're not getting them to leave you're
not but i don't i don't think he's i
don't see i don't think he's a the high
function alcoholic where he's winning
championship fights right
i think alcohol obviously he likes to
party and stuff like that but i don't
think it's like a leaving las vegas
necklace type of thing yeah well i think
i think he's a wild dude that
makes a lot of bad decisions i think he
does a lot of cocaine probably does all
the cocaine that's not going to work out
again no one has done a lot of cocaine
where it works out it just doesn't
you're going to make you're going to
make bad decisions all the way around
there's just no consequences for his
actions that's the thing that's like he
always skates by
well the judge can't look at like that
previous stuff and go like all right bro
we got to make a bigger change
what do you know what do you what change
do you do you toss him in prison
what do you do when are you when artie
lang was in rehab with lawrence taylor
lawrence taylor
looked at him and said
you are i was the greatest football
player on earth you are being a
don't it up the way i do you know
blah blah blah and he said and he said
to artie he said i never played a game
sober sober he never played he was never
on the field where he wasn't
doing blood but back then the nfl didn't
they don't test but in the ufc if john
was on that stuff that trust me he
wouldn't fight yeah he wouldn't be able
to you mean they would have seen the
coke in the system
yeah so we know he's not fighting like
that you know it's not like a lawrence
taylor type of thing
i yeah i just i don't know what you do
with them man also you know yeah you
deal with people who have uh substance
abuse stuff like that
there comes a point i'm sure that you
have seen it seems like dana's that
point where you're just like dude figure
it out man like i'm sick of dealing with
this dude figure it the out it's a
pattern and then you realize like
they're never gonna get better if you're
gonna have a relationship with them this
is what it is
and you just gotta deal with it if you
there's
like or don't give it too much energy
like like dana said like i expected this
like it doesn't surprise me unless
you're sober unless you're truly sober
yeah unless you there's no there's no
talking does that how do you know an
addict's lying when their lips are
moving they'll do whatever they they
have to to protect that
they're gonna go back to the the
vampires yeah they're gonna go back
until they hit rock bottom and they can
never and it's such a shame like how
long of a rope do we give this dude
you know because he's the best fighter
on the planet
imagine this
anybody else imagine if anybody else did
this last few fights he hasn't finished
anybody he goes to decisions now it's
like it's like he has this product that
we're dying to see anymore yeah
it's been a minute since though the
heavyweight thing was the one that we
were just hoping the heavyweight thing
was kind of a new lease on his life you
know as far as his career because like
yeah that'd be sick man yeah
everywhere
i think he's dealt with that heavyweight
man
you do yep now he's blown but he's i
guess he's like walking around 270 or so
260 right now is he there trying to be
275. yeah once you cut down from 275 but
it's like all right so you can go pound
for pound with the big boys they woke up
like that you get up
yeah
i don't agree with it yeah
i don't know if we'll see it though and
i
for the first time in life i don't give
a i'm out dude
i'm out here nope i'm out when when i
saw the kid told the security guards i
have kids i'm like oh i'm out that's
what happened a piece of man yep
i'm out when you have kids you can't
take it sucks man because you know
exactly what those kisses do you know
exactly
your son's a very good hair stylist by
the way
he's not so funny
he's so weird i mean she's like dad
cause i gotta always like do this i'm
like i don't want to do that i love that
just okay
it's the best
what's the best all right you're my
stylist
what are you doing
[Music]
yeah
you
he said i'm okay with it
i don't know dude
do it now you think
yeah
nice to meet
like this
i like that i like gianni's comment i
know he doesn't like
yeah we took the summer off but now now
it's checking i can't do a hot tub
that's people oh yeah
oh yeah does he still have that haircut
no his hair is like on the right it's
just long oh okay oh that's right
that's pretty dope i see him around
studio city sometimes that looking kid
he did it ashley simpson yes that's
right yeah
rock band yeah actually simpsons with uh
diana yeah diana ross's son that's right
is that santa ross's daughter no no no
he uh ashley simpson's with uh diana
diana diana ross's uh son what's he do
he's an actor he's an actor
okay
he
yeah evan ross
that's them okay well he's an atl yeah
he's an atheist yep oh that's a good
show
movie right no no the the movie
oh i'm thinking of uh atlanta with
childish gambino yeah
that's him in atl right yeah okay it was
quite some time ago
yeah
he's in the you know
come on his mom
come on meatball you know about evan
ross right
you know something sure
cool
not recognizing these movies
the lowest boy in the world yeah yeah
i've never yeah all right well no okay
so these he's working though at least
yeah he was in the hunger games
oh yeah i am mockingjay that's a big
movie yeah yeah
one and two okay yes yeah
masala all right he's working good for
him yeah
well
[Music]
what else you got chin
we have the jon jones stuff in there but
yeah i mean you covered everything
oh my god it's a bummer ashley simpson
is uh looks very different than when i
knew her she did no job right yeah the
nose job changed a lot and got it done
why wouldn't you though yeah if i had a
daughter she had a beacon like
okay as soon as you turn 18 we're
shaving i got to know that family i got
to know that family they're great
they're great people man so you know
nick lachey too i met him a couple times
when i was shooting the show but but
she's a doll and her her sister's great
they're both great people they're both
disciplined they were raised by their
father and their mother
very close religious but also
disciplined hard-working and good to
everybody both of them they're both both
of those girls
i think we i think we all like them
brian everybody likes jessica all right
in case there any he's all you son of a
they are not racist
i choose to defend
everyone's looking around like all right
i love how he was just going i'm just
saying guys in case anybody has all the
positives you take it up with me
i will defend them to the last fight oh
actually yeah she had an album too she i
think she did one there's nothing better
she should sing no there's nothing
better when she wants saturday night
live
singing and the track starts and then it
goes before and then she looks at the
band she does like this she starts doing
like a hoe down there runs off stage
no yeah it's a sunday and then she's all
and she has like this weird little shift
yeah you know the song
yeah it her yeah oh boy yeah
maybe she's doing fine
no you get out of here chien go the real
one man there's not this weird ass lady
talking about it
here we are yeah here it is it's right
after
watch
you feel bad
look should i have the mic we're gonna
dance
[Music]
oh no watch this watch this little jig
she does look
then she goes
ah i don't think she knew it was look at
her
i don't know what she just wouldn't
start singing
because i don't think
[Applause]
why didn't she just sing it
i don't know
i like how the band just kept going look
at the band you gotta come out and sing
yeah you gotta get back in there girl
she's just thinking the show must
go on
it's live ladies yeah dude
it happens i like the little jake she
did yeah she did a little hold down
little a little dosey though it's
awkward huh yeah
dude you can't lip-sync huh no i think a
lot of people do but yeah you got to
know your i didn't know that
they did but something with the
recordings today like can
fix people's voice voices to where
they sound like they're actually good
singers yeah but a lot of times when
they do the live
stuff
they aren't sure yeah
and that's why they lip-sync yeah yeah
yeah they can actually do their songs
but everything's in racks and it's
auto-tuned either like through software
or they have a rack it's auto-tuned so
they could just sing the way they do and
sound just like almost like yeah
no she does not oh wait no she's amazing
amazing
no
you know this really nice person jessica
simpson guys
is it 1998
you know who can sing chin
out of all the names
jennifer
you're old dude
i didn't think he was going to say
jennifer hudson of all people and then
everyone's just like i was expecting
everybody
i was expecting everybody to go you
brian hit it there that's right
and then it's like obvious well yeah
playing aretha franklin in her bio oh
yeah no i know i mean yeah dream girl
that's what i'm saying she's a beast she
can play around that's like my dad i was
telling my dad about the broncos and i
go you know we're undefeated we're the
first place in the fc west it's just the
old person thing they just defend it to
the death man my dad goes yeah that that
terry bridgewater man he's pretty good i
go
uh teddy and he goes excuse me i go his
name's teddy bridgewater dad you're
talking about the star in quebec
pretty sure it's terry i went
hey dad can't double that i did dad
i'm telling you his name's teddy dude
and he goes well then in case all the
media out here is saying it wrong pretty
sure it's terry i just went
you know what i went it it's terry
man you go go tell your friends it's
terry you gotta you gotta take your
elves as you get older you gotta be like
all right all right you're dead taking
that part of the show part of the show
is that you can call him whatever you
want but around denver call him terry
all right well her name's teddy that's
pepper yeah he doubled down okay i guess
nine news out here is wrong
i think you can't hear dude how about
that you guys bump heads oh yeah i
farted yesterday
you farted and my girl sat down and she
goes you just farted and i said
no i didn't
she goes of course you did i'm sitting
here i said i smell it too
she goes where are you going i don't
know what's going on
she goes she looks at me she goes are
you serious
i go yeah i would tell you i don't know
why
why couldn't you just tell i just
decided to lie yeah you're like it
and then you were already there you
already committed
terry it was a terry teddy thing yeah
who else was it who else was it the
but also
politics i messed some names up but man
when it comes to football i mean come on
dad
teddy just laugh and go right it's teddy
yeah i'm getting better about it just
being like all right whatever dude well
you're dead your dad's an alpha and you
guys tend to butt heads yeah yep like
siamese fish yeah what don't you got gin
yeah
alrighty but j-lo
j j hud
oh you know there's a new doc on britney
spears it's just yeah on netflix has
anybody seen it
apparently i have recordings that her
dad recorded her
uh there are i think the fbi is
investigating a lot of the claims from
that netflix documentary now holy i
think the dad's oh the dad's
really yeah yeah and the mom and
the business manager like they were just
siphoning because you just had momentum
announced her retirement everyone on her
team for the past 13 years just suddenly
dipped and said oh well she's retiring
we want to support her now and her
decision but it's because no one can
make money off her anymore that's dicey
man
and so so i guess the dad like his
defense is like yeah i was recording her
because she was doing drugs and i was
making sure the drug dealer went that's
a felony in in los angeles but then he
did it for like that would like maybe
that was an initial he had a good you
know intent which again is against the
law whatever your intent was but he just
break was like yeah i should leave it in
there yeah you're not like years
like just recording her like you cannot
record somebody um
if you're recording somebody in
california without their consent so if
you record a phone call if you record a
conversation you have you come in and
they don't know about it it's a crime
that's what happened with kanye west and
taylor swift during that phone call oh
and only in california there are certain
states where it's fine so new york state
i believe you can do that in new york
and california you are not allowed to do
that so
unless there's a crime being committed
if there's a crime being committed then
that will stand so if somebody says i'm
going to kill you and cut your throat
and you record that yeah you're alright
but otherwise no and so with this case
he's in deep if she wants to bring
charges he's in trouble yeah i think
he's what does she get jim all
right
so a 30 year old woman from the bay area
recently went on a hike which led to the
fires over in i forgot which county but
so she's at 30. yeah norcal she is a 30
year old former yoga teacher who was in
a hike she ran out of water was very
thirsty she found a puddle on the floor
and thought oh it's water i'm gonna
drink it shortly upon taking a few sips
she realizes that it's bare urine and so
she tries to filter it out with a tea
bag that doesn't work so she then tries
to boil it in order to make it drinkable
she couldn't get it done she drinks it
anyways and it starts a fire just on a
hike that's still going on right
now
was she like missing or how long you
know out there she was out there now for
about i think a few days ago started
drinking beer piss yeah she probably
didn't know it was bear piss no she does
she said that it was bear piss and then
she tried to boil it out so it would be
drinkable yes like a heavy like beer
piss a lot of piss but it wasn't and you
just like woke up at hibernation just
pissed
just that dark
hibernation
probably tastes like a warm ale get let
me see a bear pissing and did it let me
see a bear did it have uh was it did it
piss in a bowl i mean what what it was
on the floor she said it was a puddle of
piss
yeah i don't know if i'm buying she
knows it's a bear piss
could have been a fat ass moose or elk
like how do you know it's a bear yeah
right a bear specifically it's right
there it's him today there he goes it's
not even that hard yeah right now i'll
piss hard scratching the back too
yeah that's not bad at all i love it
tiny pee pee too for a big animal yeah
well
well that ain't dude
it's definitely not bear piss no it's
natural
sounds like she might be full of
what ha so if you create the forest
fires and all that how's that
effect like obviously you don't
like if you did unintentionally right
like you didn't mean to do it
unintentionally what happened you still
pay the you'd pay the fines because
there was
the the fire can't be cheap
dude burning hundreds of acres they're
like well here's your bill how much we
burned five hundred thousand acres of
forests it's a lot of just run through
the numbers it's just the timber
oh here we go 177 million
all right
are you related jeff bezos no okay so i
got bad news really bad news yeah about
the people who started the wildfire from
the baby the baby baby gender
announcement yeah they have to pay all
that and i think they could have faced
jail time trying to buy a tree go see
how much one oak tree called it it'll
cause it'll run you yeah and then
millions of them down yeah but the thing
is like how's that work so let's see him
and his wife make let's say 100 grand
between the two of them you know what do
you do you're not you're just working
for the rest of your life you're
basically a slave to this part yeah i
don't think i think there's a reasonable
there's a direction they have to well
but also the government's like dude
they're never yeah it was
a trillion dollars
you might as well say you you always
really do i think what happens is you at
the end of the day people go
sorry
you know you can barely get sorry out
you know how sometimes you really yeah
well you know you really like
this you go
i'm sorry or the government just you
know what you're doing you really
what the did you do
sorry i think the government just
garners your wages like that's where
they discipline they probably take out
for your check all the time you have to
take this as an answer
yeah i mean even if you gave them a
million they got a million dollars to
the government whoops does it say how
much those the her fines were yeah it
says on there the fine that she might
have to
pay but she did end up because of that
fire
144 houses were burned down so like
she's open
what does she do getting sued by those
homeowners as well i mean
you guys think you should this is
different this is like tickets
government fines go go goes
i would put in catastrophic no
[Laughter]
like which one i know they're trying to
figure it out too ah five years in
prison and find so much it's 250 000.
that's probably minimum
chin pull up the original article again
because i'm pretty sure it hasn't
accidentally started forcing you see
where it says she's a self-described
shaman so she's full of yeah yeah
off the bat yeah so there was no bear
piss
i smelled from the jump
bear piss even the judge like how do you
know that
how do you know like it's not like oh
there it goes science grad
self-described shaman yoga teacher and
dive master
all just yeah
dude
you're in her face she doesn't look like
she's real
she she well she looks shell shocked
she's like yeah yeah um
that's i up um
that's a lot yeah yeah she's gotta go to
the squid game by the way
yeah by the way that's what happens
you're a contestant in squid
and you could win a lot or get shot in
the you must've been a
smart girl cal tech oh yeah she must
have been smart sure but just you know
sometimes not great with forrest fenn it
doesn't mean you're good at fire
no sometimes you just you make a fire
and you're like it's dry here
you have the government i don't know
what you do you know i mean you just you
know you go you can't start a fire in
the woods it's not a good idea
in august yes if you're in british
columbia and it rains all the time the
rain forest you're going to be fine
sure
not in northern california what else you
got you
god damn that's crazy
so a few day days ago a photo of the set
of studio rules from dj mustard's studio
leaked and it was on instagram a lot of
people were mad about it because one of
his rules are like no ugly people uh
that's fair like no ugly energy and
there was so much backlash that he made
it an updated one that he posted himself
basically explaining like you're not
ugly based off your look you're ugly
based off like your energy and stuff
like that initially hearing that that
that's why i took it as like oh no a lot
of people thought it was more so like oh
like no ugly what that's what
people took at us
it sounds like he's being silly and
funny too is that possible no negative
nancies be happy to even breathe in the
same air as the grammy award winning 100
million records selling
like me that's my life
then he has like the explanation so all
these rules are still good let's see
this do not come to my studio if you're
ugly this has nothing to do with how you
look it's about the energy you're
putting out yes there's such thing as
ugg you have to personality he means
ugly i get it man uh if you do
not hit the gym today if you did not hit
the gym today go the home this rule
is to motivate i'm not perfect
but i'm not who i was back then i'm
always trying to better myself it's just
an ego thing uh and yes i hit the gym
every day will be doesn't look like it
uh do not come in my room just look at
what the i'm doing can contribute
or leave
no negative nancy yeah all
right don't don't finish five brendan
don't forget uh be happy to even breathe
the same air as a grammy award you
finish it for 100 million records
selling ninja like me
high vibes only no negatives
all this is fine i have no sympathy for
lazy ninjas
do me another favorite don't do me no
face it sounds awful you know
small talk my team and i got to do
sounds terrible think before saying dumb
my security is armed and he will
drag your ass out of here behind your
business he sounds terrible but
he's really good yeah he's real he's
really really good create some beats hey
he it's his studio so it's john jones
is that that's for his studio right yeah
that's for his he can do whatever
he wants no i know but it's just that
that doesn't make for a great working no
that doesn't make look for what you do
what happens in those situations
what happens in those situations is as
soon as you start producing and as soon
as those people that you create quiet
resentment
and when you do that you'll those people
will find if they're given an
opportunity they will
get back at you because you that's
humiliating you're putting yourself on
such a high level it's tough because
he's like the ceo right so that's yeah
yeah it's his he's really good
i mean he's really it's not
really that's pretty hard but i i see
what you're saying though it's an
outdated way to treat your employees
yeah yeah that's probably a better way
to go this is what they talk about being
a toxic work environment all that
but
it's it's a real thing so he's also
dealing with a lot of rappers though
that's a good point he's dealing with
some knuckles yeah he's dealing with
nothing
he's
he might have written all that off
because he was so fed up and so he's
getting a compliment and he's a and he's
a driven dude it's a compliment to his
son he's a he's a driven dude i sing
well what's that yeah he's probably a
driven dude
he's sick of the ball he might have
written that when he was just like
everybody's an idiot yeah yeah
yeah
and like he deals with some hardcore
dudes yeah people like a lot a lot of
like
guys waste his time making up his
promises so he's probably he's probably
he probably sat down all pissed off and
was like if you ugly do not come in this
spirit yeah i don't have a problem with
it yeah is he a british rapper is he
american no no he's american he's uh
he's a producer he's based out of l.a
yeah he's from l.a but this reminded me
of the list of rules that uh steve
harvey had that remember that went viral
wait what did he have he's great
basically like oh uh don't bring people
into my dressing room because a lot of
people will bring family members or
friends on stage
oh god that dude's amazing yeah he's
still doing stand up on a high level
that is no he retired from stand
up yeah he tried to well whatever but
did you see him do that
the sp do you see that stand up when he
did the sp yeah he does he doesn't tour
though oh he doesn't yeah he doesn't
tour did you stand up but he's doing it
right funny dude yeah steve harvey i got
love watching like i'll watch family
feud clips just
because he says funny how would he
i guess he just didn't want to just
stand up and watch foreign yeah he
retired back in 2012 yeah it's been a
hot second yeah
yeah crushed that yeah he i think he did
a special he did a special he's wearing
like a white suit
he's pretty funny
yeah king the comedy yeah yeah he's a
monster monster cedric the entertainer
he's still tourists
monsters
insane just he's great
it's obvious wednesday with brian cowan
do you know who i like you crushed it
eddie murphy dude on stage
eddie murphy and for any of you that
don't think he's a good comic he was
supposed to come back and he never did
the pandemic the pandemic
it stopped touring because he didn't
want to really especially was he doing
yeah he was yep he's going around
doing the pandemic kid and just shut it
down
so i don't know that i really want to
see
i loved it i loved to i watched his when
he was on snl last time he was on snl
back in
it was like right before the pandemic as
well too
oh yeah yeah he was he was he was
he
brought back some of his old characters
too
[Music]
let me refresh
there we go okay so will smith recently
did an interview with gq trying to
defend his wife because a lot of people
look at their marriage and think that
jayda was the one cheating because agus
alcina came out said that he had an
affair with her yeah and he came out and
said that they both don't have a
monogamous relationship she grew up in a
lot of situations where family members
didn't have monogamous marriages they
always had open relationships so that's
what she knew as normal and that's what
she wanted a few years into their
marriage so he's basically coming out
saying yes we did have an open
relationship and really yeah they oh
they still haven't they both yeah yeah
so yeah i don't get that either what
works for him who gives a right i
think he's more so public backlash from
just because they're so high profile a
lot of people don't like the idea of an
open relationship but what does it have
to do with anyone else yeah right
i don't get why
maybe people are piling on jada for
cheating on him and he's like wait no
don't give her too much of a hard time
yeah yeah oh got it
yeah yes she brought that his name
augusta or some like
they get brought him to like the family
vacation in hawaii that'd be weird oh
really yeah that feels like you're the
fighter that is
awkward
that would be the young man me
tonight
husband right how do you explain that to
your kids when they're young
i mean they're not too young they raised
those kids they were back
back then they were kids those kids are
not very convinced those kids they and
that's what she says they didn't raise
them conventional she's like we don't
believe in discipline stuff like that
you know they seem like good kids yeah
absolutely they're they're definitely uh
they're different they seem to be diffie
but like good kids will willow came out
with like a rock album and everything
yeah sure so make you a good kid coming
out with a rock album though what'd you
say that doesn't make you a good kid i
mean we've seen we're celebrity kids
though
uh bring them up yeah but you don't you
don't really hear about them like you
would other celebrity kids though i
don't hear about it i think it's
difficult when you grow up like like
royalty it's hard to navigate maybe
something but they've actually done
pretty like like uh jada jaden was a
good actor he was good and yeah
for the younger crowd his music is
big yeah yeah they're bigger
he does beautiful children yeah they are
and i think jaden
identifies as pansexual
yeah i think so
all right good for her yeah that's it no
no that's why she does or does the sun
does i think i think the sun does well
they look is that very similar is that
her yeah yeah she's pretty right
yeah look at her playing guitar killing
it
well your dad's will smith man you
better be pretty good at entertaining
can she play chapel yeah like really
playing i'm telling you she's yeah she
dropped it yes let me see there let me
see yeah they've done pretty good
career-wise right she looks great there
let me see a picture of her i mean that
video
um there's a video of her playing
didn't you do snl recently that's like a
trailer
so most people how do you not go to this
bruh so mostly because i'm not 13.
[Music]
yeah so most people don't know jada
jada pinken uh uh also had a metal band
it was called wicked wisdom oh wow yeah
bro they were all like uh so that's what
she's doing yeah they had a spot uh
i think they did the oz fest
one year wow and then uh yeah there's
like a conan set
of uh her banner yeah
chin go to youtube yeah and then jaden
is uh the model for louis
vuitton
it's good looking kids man yeah will you
go to
uh we can't play that stuff though
but you could just see her oh just see
her yeah just like she's like rocking
the out type in wicked wisdom jaden
smith or uh the the mom
jada pika yeah oh my god
oh look at her yeah you don't have to
listen that's what she used to do no i'd
love to hear it
this is her on jay leno yeah
bleed all over me yeah and it was like
give me a tow mater
does it say yeah
you don't know about this no
yeah i don't know too much about her
this is chair to pink it yeah
she had a huge music career
that guy's intense that guy is so
drugged up
[Music]
with low interest rates is a great time
to refinance your student loans earnest
offers low rate student loan refinancing
you can check your rates risk free in
just two
minutes with earnest you get flexible
payments you can pick your loan term by
refinancing to reduce your loan term
save money combine multiple loans and
there's one simple monthly payment all
right isn't it time to stop feeling
overwhelmed with your student debt we
got you covered man ernest is offering
the viewers and listeners the fighter in
the kid 100 cash bonus rate refinance
your student debt at earnest.com fighter
terms conditions apply ernest is giving
you guys again 100 bonus refinance your
student loans at earnest.com fighter
terms and conditions apply ernest is
giving you guys again 100 bonus
refinance your student loans at
earnest.com fighter terms and conditions
apply visit earnest.com fighter for more
details terms conditions apply earn a
student loan refinance made by earnest
operations llc and mls number one two
zero four nine one seven california
finance and law license number six zero
five four seven eight eight three oh 303
second street suite 401 north san
francisco california
94107 if you're still listing visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses
this episode of fire kit is brought to
you by on it supplements
time to get in shape man the holidays
are coming up and i know your thick ass
is gonna be eating a ton of food so
might as well get in shape now and so
you know you don't feel as bad when you
start
just going ham during christmas
thanksgiving don't wait for january
first get your thick ass in shape but if
you're gonna do it you need the best
supplements in the world we talking
about on it how many times i've heard me
say on it on any podcast that i do
it.com slash fighter 10 off every
frickin thing you need to get your ass
in shape we got creatine we got shroom
tech protein powders coffee warrior bars
protein bars protein bites streaming
fitness streaming fitness kettle bells
primal bells quad maces steel maces we
have if you're if your thick ass want to
stay home all right and you don't want
to go to the gym we have streaming
fitness on-demand fitness you can do it
from your freaking phone no more excuses
all right on it dot com slash fighter 10
off
this is so awkward right what it is it
just doesn't you know what you're
holding your own thoughts
it doesn't seem like a fit
i find her painfully attractive though
she's so so she's gorgeous like
especially back then she's so hot like
she's so in my wheelhouse
everyone thinks she's hot i'm not the
only one god i'm not the only one but
that is hey guys i'm going to live here
she's attractive
a lot of people say she's ugly
the wife of will smith is this episode
called captain obvious
we call it captain obviously now hold on
tupac but that is a little yeah
yeah she dated tupac that is a little
awkward though huh no i think it's fine
do what you
yeah it's just i don't know but you can
tell why willow does it now because her
mama's doing it yeah she's
pretty
willow doesn't make like hard music like
her mom was like
no hers is kind of like alternative yeah
hers is more alternative she's just
she's a force of nature i mean that's
why she yeah she's good everybody she
wanted and
she has
back in the day i mean she's just
undeniable dated tupac she was working
she would have been successful she was
working i think we talked about how he
was jealous or not jealous of the tupac
really or just
something he said something about better
things jealousy
what else you got jen jesus christ
well the more you know huh
amazing that's crazy
there you are
um
what's them together
they're hugging
okay so i don't know how to go with it
i had the same thing too i don't know
what else they could bring to the second
part
does he make money off this tiger king
is coming out with a second season i
believe it comes out in november i don't
know if he come he's going to get any
money i know he probably gets paid for
certain days that he works if they'd
have to yeah yeah or unless he's not
unless he signed away a huge contract at
the beginning
i don't know i just don't know where you
go with the second season
but carol baskin is very upset that
tiger king season two is happening i
think it's because they painted her in
such a bad light in the first one
with her yeah she's potentially
allegedly murdering her it probably
ruined her life she probably gets
harassed all the time every day probably
for a hot second she was
they were making all these memes and all
that it's a real thing yeah that said
that's her she became a tick-tock dance
she became a yeah someone made a remix
to uh savage by megan the stallion but
it was tiger king and it was about uh
carol baskin killing her husband
and everyone was doing dances to it
yeah her killing the husband thing was
dicey
putting sardine oil on his shoes or some
well she only has five thousand
followers
verified she probably deleted the thing
she has a podcast
big cat rescue
okay well all right i have no idea what
that talks gonna be about
all right manny pacquiao retired
he's gonna run for president he said to
focus on his political career so yeah
definitely i feel like it's dangerous
running against that i agree duterte
yeah i agree
but that's great that he's doing it
because that guy he's always been
involved with politics correct yeah yeah
yep
i love him out there
shout out to him he's phenomenal man
great best calves in the game crazy
speed
good box who was it de la hoya said i
can deal with his
power i just can't deal with speed i
think that's what he said when he sat
down came back it's like i don't know
what the this guy's doing
a legend man
you know what he was a great boxer
dude i'm gonna go right now
throw it in boxes
good boxing what else yeah i'll
say great boxer brandon and i don't care
what anybody understands anybody in this
room says otherwise you guys
don't know and i will defend that
to the end what's weird about this is uh
i heard he didn't get booed
like he was getting cheered there were
two videos from two different sides of
the crowd one made it look like he was
getting booed because that side of the
crowd was booing him like crazy and then
because he went hard at i think
of course yeah it was like a bag
you know why did he go bad on slipknot
there was something like getting
together well yeah yeah um he was giving
the lead singer slipknot direction and
he was like oh you know
not for me you know i write he goes i'd
rather just do what i would want to do
to the to help the song and he goes but
no no hard feelings or anything he goes
i don't think i'm the guy for this song
that's what corey taylor said yeah
because he was originally supposed to be
on their track yeah on a yeah travis
barker had hit him up and was like yo
you know would love to let me say it
yeah yeah but i guess corey taylor said
something about
uh switching genres
you know of music because
mgk was a rapper and then went to
like pop punk or whatever and i guess he
said some but he never said mgk's name
but he said just
people switching switching genres
machine gun kelly yeah and he said i i
said uh at least i'm not 50 years old
wearing a mask on stage yeah it's fair
points and then uh
yeah and then oh and then yeah so yeah
so but they were they headlining this
concert is that why you got booed uh
slim knot was also on that yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they have a huge house
okay alumni has a mat like it's i mean
all right
yeah
look at them right there they are that
slipknot yeah that's a lot of makeup
that's got to be right that's not really
that's a mess okay they're amazing
though oh dude live yeah they're amazing
live do you still have your slipknot
you've never heard of a costume from
last year yeah i've heard of him yeah
yeah they're huge yeah
yeah well he always puts on the hard
rock thing
also it pops up yeah and then the
playlists streaming things that's
intense why are they really yeah i've
seen i've seen them quite a few times
not good it's just they're great they're
great it sounds like they're soulful i
mean yeah
yeah yeah they're great they help you
get out a lot of a lot of yeah you
know i went to my first concert in a
while last uh the other night too
it felt great man just big
slipknot they've been around
uh try to listen to a song called wait
and bleed yeah that shows you the two
sides of slipknot yeah soulful and
awesome
the singer's a really good singer yeah
you're a really good team yeah yeah
machine gun kelly's primarily a rapper
he was alright and now he's now he
linked up with travis park and he's now
like pop yeah but i bet he could like
him making that pop punk album he
probably has always had that in him he's
probably been able to yeah he's like you
don't just start like yeah he plays the
guitar on it too so it's like he'd
probably chin go back a couple there's a
uh
uh maybe we should slip knowing no there
was this
never mind it just looked like something
worth watching
it's like i don't know if it's
where they have like the two fitness
coaches get swept up oh i don't want to
see that because that's right yeah it's
right it was real
where were they i guess two fitness
coaches and uh the wife some wife of one
of them they one guy jumped in the other
guy tried to save him they both died i
think the wife died too or something
like that i just
yeah it was on camera the wife was
taping
i don't know that's what i mean that's
why i'm like
that's so crazy but by the way i don't i
don't see that yeah it was just like a
superstar
that's why i wanted to see if that was
real um this was real though that's
terrible brennan but what they were they
seemed dangerous c could be dangerous
they were just like they were two
fitness coaches i think they were trying
to help her they were trying to show
themselves diving like it was cool but
the water was just too crazy let's just
read if you want to read the story
your fitness is not enough to fight the
sea sometimes and i think that's what i
wanted to say that okay if she takes you
she takes you
i know
films are fitness coach and husband
drawn alongside a woman died spanish
waves damn 30 and 24. well spanish waves
have always been known as very big the
waves when you see the video i just saw
a glimpse of it they were crazy in the
video the woman is heard historically
crimes appear watch out but she stayed
filming it yeah i guess she was probably
trying to you should probably yeah she
probably didn't know what the hell she
was doing she probably didn't know that
they were dying you know she's freaking
out i don't know yeah
okay that was terrible though she's like
god no god no swipe up we got no you
know it's like what
yeah i don't know you put a filter on
that
it's weird like
it's terrible i i i
i was in the bahamas i remember me and
my buddy of the bahamas were in high
school
and he got caught in the waves dude and
i went out to try to save him
those waves were so big we just
kept getting tumbled and tumbled
and i got on shore in this big
muscular
bohemian guy no just grabbed him ran out
and grabbed him he was like this he was
a macho kid too he's like
like it's scariest oh it's terrifying i
got caught in a riptide in uh huntington
beach yeah i was i was terrified we
weren't even in like we could stand he
could stand where he was getting crashed
oh really he couldn't get out i was just
kept getting sucked back out boom
you know it's the ocean that'll exhaust
you just a quick story so uh you know
have you guys gone tubing
on a river oh you went to the you went
to the salt river not this time though i
went before and before me and my
girlfriend got together we were friends
at that time
she was getting swept away so she was
like help so i tried to help her it's
like literally like
maybe like two feet of water yeah just
rushing so i tried to help her then i
got messed up so she i pushed her away
and i started oh crap i'm gonna lose it
and some big girl actually grabbed me
and pulled him oh yeah yeah i got it we
got we went on the saco river a bunch of
kids didn't know about white water
or anything else you know saco right
well sometimes the saco can get pretty
nasty
long story short it was supposed to be a
four day five day trip the first day we
get everybody gets tossed
i just see my buddy bro i see my buddies
just go
i couldn't believe that fast he was just
going changing all the way down did he
die uh he did not die he did not die
because hey because real quick does
anyone else have any water stories that
nobody died but i'll say this almost
died
we all survived
everyone's
[Applause]
and then you know someone pulled me to
shore i'll do one that's every story
that's pretty good yeah because
it got bent around a rock and got bent
the steel canoe just got bent that's how
strong the water was now i'm holding out
of a branch my buddy's like i'm
dying and he goes under and i just reach
and all i did was like he's right here
and i just grabbed him pulled him out
that's just grabbing him yeah
yeah here you go
yeah he grabs on so that's what we're
doing yeah and then the alligator go by
the best part of this because if anyone
else shares
no no he's got the best part
i faster his life because he looked at
me he goes you saved my life now that
story the game of telephone brian became
the lifesaver yeah and i didn't do
anything to change that narrative you
just let it ride i was the i was i saved
his life
and his parents came up to me and said
thank you for saving this i'll dab you
over they'll give you money uh they
didn't give me any money brandon oh no
no dowry nope and you know and i'll tell
you something else we expect a little
gift no i'll tell you another story i
don't remember that story yeah a lot of
that story is very foggy to me i just
and when i said that the canoe was bent
over i believe that i believe that but
that never happened but i let that stuff
go i believe that the
the canoe is bent around the rock so a
lot of this stuff is it was a long time
ago
it was about 40 years ago and then it's
even more out of history right a little
bit history works
so you have to ask yourself it did
happen i do it did happen
to that magnitude that's the question no
more river stories guys maybe somebody
did die i can't remember that would be
fun
maybe somebody we lost somebody we never
found them who the knows that could
happen i know that there were crocodiles
that's the only thing that i do know
that's dangerous yeah
is that it that's it
okay guys denver me and chappelle lacey
wearing this yeah we're on the same
flight uh denver colorado tomorrow night
thursday friday saturday denver colorado
comedy works downtown las vegas nevada
is next week october 7th through the 9th
then brea california october 15th
through the 17th
and then november 11th through the 13th
we have dallas addison improv tickets at
fatkz.com
i'm going to be in chicago schomburg
improv this weekend thursday friday
saturday get your tickets now september
30th october 1 and 2 still haven't
changed that i'm not
good uh then i got columbus ohio you
know columbus funny bone october 8th and
9th that's a friday saturday then i'm
gonna be at mcgooby's joke house brandon
legumes that's right timonium maryland
let me know how it is
you gotta fly into uh washington dc and
drive about an hour and 15. can't fly
into baltimore no no because getting
there well that takes for ever
well dude
chicago is not the best flight columbus
beast magooby's beast east ohio liberty
town b east we got some beasts we got so
my my october is a tough one yeah daddy
stays
understand and i understand it's a tough
one yeah uh november november i'm i've
got some florida going on i got some
stuff see i got florida coming up it's
four that's even further i got in april
tampa florida october
and i got raleigh north carolina let's
not forget about that yay i'll do this
i'll get it yeah
i'm sorry
chappelle some side splitters tampa
tampa flight over seventh through the
ninth you going far yeah i'm going far
and then i go far again for washington
dc october 28th through the 30th comedy
yeah
uh you know where that one no probably
good though pretty nice it's fun because
the improv is not open there yet
they're still filming there are they
really yep that is a mainstay the improv
and dc is one of the most the best clubs
ever yeah i did it one time i did what
frank caliendo that's what i do
is great great great club yeah they're
some they're not open they're half
capacity still there's something weird
still still in dc yeah oh in washington
what a surprise yep all right love you
guys denver see you this week